You're not appreciating
my situation!
JEFF GREENE: You're not
giving respect to my appre--
-(LAUGHING)
-DIRECTOR: And cut.
♪ (UPBEAT MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
Ha. Who's most likely
to break during a scene?
That's easy. Larry.
Every single time.
Larry will always break first.
Even when Larry is smirking
or laughing,
I try to keep my composure.
I had a lady give me a wedgie
with my own goddamn Johnson.
(LAUGHS)
-MAN: That's amazing.
-Say that again.
-Oh, fantastic!
-Right?
SUSIE ESSMAN:
Watching Larry laughing...
(LAUGHING)
...even though I get annoyed
at him sometimes,
'cause he's ruining
all my best takes,
making him laugh is one of
the greatest joys of my life,
watching him break up.
Did I not just say to you
that I appreciate--
Are you getting appre--
-(LAUGHING)
-(CELLPHONE RINGS)
Hold on one second.
♪ (MUSIC CONCLUDES) ♪